und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend in der Ukraine hatten sie es
schon befürchtet gehabt es war wieder
ein Montag mit schwerem Raketenbeschuss
in mehreren Städten einschließlich Kiew
mussten die Menschen Schutz in Kellern
und U-Bahn-Stationen suchen die
ukrainische Armee hat nach eigenen
Angaben zwar viele russische Geschosse
abfangen können aber natürlich nicht
alle bei solch massiven Angriffswellen
ist das für keine Luft Verteidigung zu
schaffen hinein bestreit ist unsere
Reporter in Kiew
Luftalarm zur Mittagszeit mitten in
Kiews Metro station zur Lotti borota
einer der weltweit schönsten U-Bahnhöfe
wird zum Luftschutzkeller für tausende
Menschen dabei hatte der Tag in der
Hauptstadt ganz friedlich begonnen Kiews
Bürgermeister macht selfies
vorgespendeten Feuerwehrautos aus
Deutschland und Entwicklungen für
Verhandlungen mit Moskau
wir sind bereit zu sprechen aber wenn
die letzte russische Soldaten verlassen
unsere Land dann können wir sprechen
weil jetzt im Moment ich sehe keinen
Sinn auch weil Russland die Ukraine
jetzt wieder mit Raketen beschießt kaum
dass die letzten Schäden gerade erst
notdürftig geflickt worden sind der
Luftalarm gilt inzwischen für das ganze
Land hier in Kiew suchen Sie Deckung
knapp 100 Meter unter der Erde nicht
einmal ihre Haustiere wollen sie dem
russischen Raketen Terror aussetzen
ich nehme den luftteil am sehr ernst
denn im Oktober haben russische Drohne
das Nachbarhaus getroffen ein Hund macht
das hier unten ganz schön nervös aber er
gewöhnt sich langsam dran
damit gerechnet dass Russland noch mal
zu schlägt dann müssen wir jetzt durch
wir haben zu Hause Vorräte angelegt vor
allem Nahrungsmittel und Wasser
während Sie hier unten entspannt sitzen
und auf ihren Handys die Meldungen von
oben verfolgen fängt die ukrainische
Luftabwehr gut 60 von über 70 russischen
Raketen ab Kiew bleibt diesmal verschont
von schlimmen Einschlägen in anderen
Regionen gibt es Tote und Verletzte von
den Strom und Wasser wieder aus
[Musik]
und just heute trat das EU-Embargo gegen
russisches Öl in Kraft die russische
Propaganda versucht das
herunterzuspielen Tenor Russland sitzt
am längeren Hebel der Westen bippert
letztens wurde von russischen Kanälen ja
schon verbreitet in ihrer Not hätten die
frierenden deutschen den Berliner
Tiergarten abgeholzt ob das in Russland
jemand glaubt wissen wir nicht
nichtsdestotrotz bleibt das Energiethema
natürlich eine Herausforderung für die
deutsche Politik dazu gehört auch die
Suche nach Partnern jenseits von
Russland oder China in diesem Sinne ist
die deutsche Außenministerin nach Indien
gereist mit Blick auf Europas
Wirtschaftskrieg mit Russland ist Indien
allerdings ein schwieriger
Gesprächspartner die Andreas Künast
man muss erst einen Kopftuch aufsetzen
sich dann die Hände und dann die Füße
waschen und erst dann darf man rein in
den Tempel der sixx in der Chanten die
chokrate von Neu-Delhi wenn man die Zeit
hat und wenn man will die Deutsche
Außenministerin will sie nimmt sich die
Zeit sich Tempel stehen allen offen es
ist wer Box Verbeugung vor Indien
Indien ist so bevölkerungsreich so
wirtschaftsstark und so selbstbewusst
wie noch nie wer in Neu-Delhi etwas
erreichen will darf dieses Milliarden
Einwohner Land ruhig loben und das
andere China ruhig kritisieren weil wir
auch im letzten Jahr auf brutale Art und
Weise gesehen haben dass wenn wir Tiefe
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen zu Partnern
haben die eben nicht Werte Partner sind
dass das volkswirtschaftlich dramatische
Folgen haben kann und dass das dann
nicht in unserem volkswirtschaftlichen
Interesse ist der indische wertepartner
teilt nicht alle Werte vor allem nicht
bärbox nicht die westliche Sicht auf
Russlands Krieg in diesem Zimmer hat ein
gewisser Gandhi gelebt ein Pazifist wie
es früher auch war an dieser Stelle ist
er erschossen worden zwei Handvoll
Rosenblätter rieseln nieder
dass sich Indien bei der Verurteilung
Russlands enthalten hat schmerzt den
Westen dass es vom Krieg profitiert
kostet während Europa die Einfuhr
russischen Erdöls nun auch mit einem
preisdeckel sanktioniert will Indien
sogar mehr in Russland kaufen die Kritik
des Westens nervt
Europa trifft seine Entscheidungen
Europa priorisiert seine
Energiebedürfnisse aber bittet uns etwas
anderes zu tun
vom Außenministerium nimmt bärbock die
U-Bahn zum nächsten Termin sie ist
Indien weit entgegengekommen aber sie
bringt nur wenig mit
in Europa ist Hauptstädten mögen sich ja
viele lieber nicht ausmalen wie es um
die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
bestellt wäre wenn in Washington nicht
Joe Biden sondern Donald Trump regieren
würde der schuldverschluss ging über
Russland hat allerdings manche
transatlantischen Konflikte nur
übertöntgt wenn es um amerikanische
Wirtschaftsinteressen geht kämpft auch
die beiden Regierungen mit harten
Bandagen ihr gewaltiges subventionspaket
hat in Europa Empörung ausgelöst in
Washington gab es dazu heute ein
Krisentreffen Claudia jetzt berichtet
in den us-nachrichten geht es um eine
Stichwahl morgen um Donald Trump es geht
um alles mögliche nur nicht um den
Streit mit der EU auch bei den Handels-
und technologiegesprächen ist für das
umstrittenste Thema nicht viel Zeit
eingeplant es ist ein europäisches
Problem und so hat Außenminister Blinken
auf die Frage ob es eine Lösung geben
wird auch nicht mehr als Verhalten
lächelndes schweigen
eine Änderung an dem US-Gesetz ist nicht
geplant
370 Milliarden Dollar für Klimaschutz
und Energiesicherheit Steuervorteile und
Subventionen für E-Autos und Projekte zu
erneuerbaren Energien allerdings nur für
made in USA Präsident beiden will dass
die USA bei erneuerbaren Energien und
Schlüsseltechnologien global führen und
er will die US-Wirtschaft ankurbeln die
EU befürchtet europäische Unternehmen
haben das Nachsehen
es gibt Teile über die wir etwas besorgt
sind das ist kein Geheimnis wir sind
sehr dankbar dass Präsident beiden
positiv darauf reagiert hat wir erwarten
eine Lösung bei E-Autos und wir erwarten
als die Partner behandelt zu werden die
wir ja sind
eine Arbeitsgruppe wird weiter nach
Lösungen suchen werden die Europäer zum
Beispiel mit eigenen massiven
Subventionen auf Konfrontationskurs
gehen oder doch eher auf
Ausnahmeregelungen für europäische
Firmen hoffen an einem Handelskrieg
zwischen den Partnern kann keine Seite
Interesse haben
bei anderen Handelsfragen sind sich
Deutschland und die USA hingegen einig
Stichwort Kampfflugzeuge Diskussionen
gab es allerdings auf deutscher Seite
Heinz Bundeskanzler Scholz hat
bekräftigt dass Deutschland
us-kampfschiffs des Typs F35 kaufen will
als Ersatz für Tornado Kampfflugzeuge
das Verteidigungsministerium widersprach
heute berichten über erhebliche neue
Risiken des Geschäfts es gebe derzeit
kein Problem in der Planung auch nicht
in der Infrastruktur sagte ein
Ministerium Sprecher
in Brüssel hat mehr als sechseinhalb
Jahre nach den schweren Terroranschlägen
dort ein Prozess gegen mutmaßliche Täter
und Helfer begonnen neun Angeklagte
stehen vor Gericht bei den Anschlägen im
März 2016 an einem Flughafen und eine
U-Bahn-Station waren 32 Menschen getötet
und Hunderte verletzt worden
bei einem mutmaßlichen messeangriff in
Iller Kirchberg nahe ulm ist eine
14-jährige Schülerin getötet worden eine
13-Jährige wurde schwer verletzt der
mutmaßliche Täter laut Polizeiangaben
ein Asylbewerber aus Eritrea sowie zwei
weitere Männer wurden in Gewahrsam
genommen weshalb es zu dem Angriff auf
die beiden Schülerinnen kam ist noch
unklar
noch kurz zu den Wetteraussichten morgen
kann es im Nordwesten und Südwesten
etwas Sonne geben sonst bleiben die
Wolken dicht im Osten regnet und schneit
es an der Nordsee kommen am Nachmittag
Schauer auf die Temperatur steigt auf
Werte von ein bis sechs Grad die
nächsten Tage bleiben wechselhaft und es
wird noch etwas kälter am Freitag gibt
es nur noch minus zwei bis plus 3 Grad
das Wasser schon von uns in dieser
kurzen Halbzeitpause um 0920 gibt es
dann unsere heute schnell Update mit
Gundula Gause und wir beide melden uns
morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]